good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight well it turns out the
DOJ failed to dictate the final result
of the 2016 presidential election
despite the fervent efforts of some of
the bureaucrats who work there but a
year and a half into the Trump
administration the Justice Department
still seems at times to be operating as
a kind of shadow government a place that
considers itself beyond the reach of
normal oversight back in the real world
congress has the explicit constitutional
power to oversee the FBI and all other
executive agencies that's the way it's
supposed to work
apparently that fact infuriates the
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
earlier this year in January Rosen Stein
threatened to subpoena the emails and
the phone records of staffers on the
House Intelligence Committee because the
committee was being too aggressive in
its probe of the Russia investigation
the message from Rosen Stein back off
you won't investigate us we will
investigate you
Fox chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge broke that story and
she has more on it tonight Catherine
well thanks Tucker the emails written on
government accounts formally documented
the January meeting for the House Office
of General Counsel the hills top lawyer
who is charged with protecting Congress
and its oversight responsibilities close
to our meeting included Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein FBI director
Christopher ray their senior advisors as
well as House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez and his senior
staff and it came with the height of
alleged government surveillance abuses
aimed at the Trump campaign today senior
lawmakers responded to allegations the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
threatened to subpoena records and
turned the tables on the republican-led
House Intelligence Committee and staff
over the Russia case it is deeply
concerning that instead of having a
cooperative relationship with this
agency respectful of the importance of
the Congress having access to documents
regarding matters that they're
investigating that they have oversight
responsibility for and this is not the
way to conduct that
well the FBI Justice Department strongly
dispute the characterization of Justice
Department official tool Fox News Rosen
Stein never threatened to anyone with a
criminal investigation House
Intelligence Committee Democrats took
aim a chairman Nunez who staffers
documented the incident I know the
reputation of rod Rosenstein and that is
one of impeccable character and I know
the reputation of Devon Nunez and that
is one of misleading obstructing
attempting to intervene in an
investigation late today chairman unis
and Republican members of the House
Intelligence Committee signed this
letter to rod Rosenstein rejecting
another briefing by the FBI Justice
Department tomorrow saying anything
short of providing the records that are
under subpoena in their opinion is an
obstruction of justice
Tucker Catherine thank you for that and
for breaking that story in the first
place rod Rosen Stein's recent behavior
is not the only example of the DOJ
apparently viewing itself as beyond
normal oversight months ago we
discovered that FBI agents Peter Strock
and Lisa page were political ideologues
whose personal views intruded on their
law enforcement duties how far did their
misconduct go and who else might be
involved the public has a right to know
that but we don't because the DOJ keeps
trying to censor the text messages
between struck and page before releasing
them here's one example in a September
2015 text struck complained about the
DOJ x' handling of a case but his exact
complaint was redacted why we don't know
but thanks to work by Senator Ron
Johnson office we know that struck was
complaining that the DOJ wanted to quote
bargain away everything and that it had
quote Stockholm Syndrome could strike
have been referring to how the DOJ
handled the Hillary Clinton email
investigation and how we did everything
it could to avoid bringing charges
against any of Clinton's team it looks
that way from the context but it's still
not clear what is clear is that nothing
struck said was a security threat that
would require a redaction in order to
protect this country
the DOJ was just trying to cover itself
to keep the public from learning the
truth about what was going on is that a
defense
Jonathan charli's professor George
Washington Law School and he joins us
tonight professor it's a very simple
question is the Department of Justice
allowed to redact information solely for
the purpose of protecting its own
reputation it is not even though it has
a long history of doing so not just in
Congress but in the court so it's really
funny is that they will
charge someone who gives the misleading
information but they'll tell Congress
that they've redacted classified
information that proves entirely
unclassified and there is this sense of
acting with utter impunity when you
redact these types of documents if you
look at the language that was uncovered
by Senator Johnson and his staff that
material is could not be considered
classified under any definition so the
question is why the committee has long
accepted this type of conduct including
Democrats they can disagree with
chairman Nunez they can disagree with
the White House but they should all
agree on the fact that this is an
improper use of redaction and it's been
going on you said for quite some times
this is basically the status quo this is
not a new way of doing business
unfortunately it is I've been counsel in
national security cases against the
government where they have redacted
material where I've objected to the
courts that it's clearly not classified
I've been allowed into skiffs or
classified settings where I've reviewed
the material and this is a recurring
complaint among council and national
security cases so in this specific case
you have the Deputy Attorney General and
no one disputes these facts that the
characterization is different on either
side but nobody disputes that rod
Rosenstein went over to the Congress and
threatened to subpoena the personal
communications of members there have you
ever seen anything like that and what
does it suggest about the relationship
between the DOJ and the Oversight
Committee well first of all it's it
really does reflect the long
mistreatment of Congress you know these
committees have not had a robust
oversight record they often roll over
this is something new and frankly those
of us who've wanted more oversight have
welcomed the last year because finally
you have a committee saying wait we're
not just going to accept any reactions
you have we're not going to take no for
an answer on something we clearly have
oversight duties now threatening whether
it's criminal or civil I staffers are
members is clearly inappropriate you
know I can understand that Rosen saying
may fell
he was being mistreated but doesn't
matter you have to get over it
he Congress created the Department of
Justice this isn't personal
it is oversight business so no matter
how aggrieved you may be you cannot
speak to an oversight committee and
threaten those staffers with taking
something like subpoenas to their
doorstep the Congress does have
oversight over the executive agencies
including the Department of Justice
correct or is that I mean watch the
other channels and you'd think that that
was something that right-wingers made up
last week but that's a constitutional
principle a my mind that says absolutely
right and you really shouldn't pick
fights with people at with oversight
power yeah I guess you shouldn't
professor thank you very much
I appreciate it Thank You Tucker